This is Jocko podcast number
one 25 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
And we are bringing a Q and
a today. Sure. To the world.
First question. Dang right
into it. Okay. All right.
What is the difference between
an excuse and a reason?
Kind of a good question, right? Sure.
Okay. And the reason it's a
good question because there's,
there can be legitimate reasons
why things happen. Yeah, right.
And so for instance, you're in a,
in a sailing race,
right?
In a sailboat and the mast snaps in half.
Now you don't win the race,
but I mean you didn't, you
know, the mass snapped.
What can you do about that?
Or the weather's horrible.
Weather rolls in and you
can't launch your aircraft.
So you can't go on your mission when you
can't control the weather. So you know,
like what's up? How can that, that's
a reason. Or you get really sick.
So you can't compete in a competition.
That's a reason.
You know you were sick or you
do bad because you were sick.
And yet it's a reason
because we called her now.
Now you could look at the
situation and say, okay,
if I'm going to take ownership or this,
did I properly test the mast?
Sure. Did I, yeah. Let me ask you this.
Did we have a ground based plan for the
operation in case the weather came in,
we were going to take vehicles instead.
Hmm. Right. Yeah, that would work.
If you get sick before the competition,
maybe you ask yourself where
are you resting properly,
where you eating properly,
going into the competition
so you wouldn't get sick.
You could address that.
Correct.
So you can still take ownership of things.
Even if the initial reaction is like,
oh there's, you can't control that.
Well then you can influence it.
You can mitigate it right now.
Can there still be legitimate reasons?
Yes, there can. And for me, the,
the,
the difference,
the line between an excuse and a reason
is a reason you have zero control over,
right. You have Z, you just have zero
control over something happening.
Well that's a reason.
Did I tell you I was almost
late the other day for something
cause this is borderline.
This is borderline. Huh?
I had an appointment at 10 o'clock
I left is a 20 minute drive.
I left an hour. I left at,
well I left about nine 10 I left 50
minutes to drive 20 minutes just so gonna
make it on time.
I get on the road basically a couple of
roads out of my house and the one entry
way to get on the freeway is locked down.
Locked down, like incident, like
isolate some incident incident.
A guy trying to kill himself on a
bridge. Shut the road down. Yeah.
So no one's going on the highway.
So what does it,
everyone's being channelized into
marginal. What are they called?
Back side streets.
Dittos rerouted.
The clock is ticking and,
and I made it right. I made
it. I was four minutes.
I had four minutes to spare. So instead
of it taking 20 minutes, it took whatever,
46 minutes,
took more than twice as long
that that could be,
you know,
a fairly legitimate reason.
Now,
luckily I had, I always, you know,
I had planned that there
could be something out of
my control and it might take
even longer and that's why I leave early
to go to an appointment or situation
like that.
So I could have also checked the
traffic prior to leaving and taking a
completely different route. That
would have been, I blamed myself.
So even in that situation I'm kind of,
I was thinking the whole time, what,
why did, why didn't I check
the traffic before I left?
I knew this could have happened.
So anyways,
in my opinion and excuses,
when you blame something that you
could have controlled and a reason is
something that you have absolutely no
control over whatsoever know you think
like a legit disease. I mean sometimes
people have, they just don't,
you can't control that.
It happens. But I think,
and I think this is the important part,
I think that what you will
find as specially when you
approached the world with
an attitude of extreme ownership and
that's that you're not going to make any
excuses.
You're not going to name it.
[inaudible] is that you actually have
a lot more control over things then you
think you do.
We've talked about this before.
When I go to the airport,
I get there really early because it's
something that you have no control over.
You're going to stand in that TSA line
and those people are going to take
forever and that's the way it is.
And if you want to get mad at them,
it doesn't matter. You can't, you can't
control, you cannot control it in any way.
You can stand at the back of my flight's
leaving in 30 minutes and there'll be
like, whatever. You should have showed
up earlier. You can't control it.
So in those situations, how do
you control it? You show up early,
you take ownership of it, you
show up early. You don't just, Oh,
I don't know what happened. The
traffic was bad. I mean it's,
there's a million excuses you can give.
If you get that attitude where
you're not going to make excuses,
you'll actually take ownership of the
things and then you'll actually solve
problems before they even happen.
If I'm going to an appointment and I have
the excuse of my back of my head that
you know what, if I'm late, I'll
just say it was the traffic.
I been much more increased
chance of being late. Yeah.
Yeah.
All right. So what's what, that's,
that's one of the things that makes
extreme ownership or hard is it hurts your
ego.
It hurts your ego.
It hurts your ego to admit that you have
control over things that went wrong.
That's that there.
It's your fault that hurts your ego.
Hmm.
It's also effective because of that.
It's effective because you solve problems.
Like I said before,
they even happen.
You solve them because you
take ownership of them.
Yeah.
Amen.
But isn't this just a
bunch of semantics though?
Like excuses and reasons re cause
really when it comes down to it,
excuse is like an excuse.
Like you're excused.
Like the reason is a reason for sure.
But it's like,
well, that's what this
whole conversation, yes,
it is about semantics and the semantics
are for me and excuse to something that
you could have controlled and a reason
is something that you could not control.
Aren't they all reasons. So
it's up to, I mean, again,
did you say tomato? I say to, I get it,
but come on and you brought
it up so you can, okay.
So I remember when I was in
elementary school. You get,
you come late to school,
you get in trouble.